entendu parler des questions cons oui on
en a parlé oui
boulanger de faire un questionnaire
d'enfer spécial pour toi je te jure
[Musique]
je vais te donner un exemple je te
mettrai pas la team pour savoir que je
peux battre magie va je sais que tu vas
voir c'est très gentille première
question mais vraiment la question
qu'ont type est ce que tu préfères
trompé ajoute amer mais j'aime les goûts
bon voilà déjà trouvé la question qu'ont
par définition c'est celle à laquelle on
ne peut pas répondre sur moi j'ai dit je
répondu ouais deuxième question c'est là
tu vois que tu pourras pas dire les deux
est-ce que tu préfère vivre disant très
très très très riche vraiment avec tout
ce que tu veux j'ai des 747
voilà alors sentant pauvre s'entend pas
avec moi que je suis pas juriste est
sûre il occupe alors troisième question
qu'on est ce que tu serais prête à
mourir là maintenant ça tu meurs
juste après la première tumeur pour que
un million de petits éthiopien puisse
survivre à ces quand même s'adresse à
régler les questions ça pourrait
s'appeler les questions cornette atitlan
mise en place qu'est ce tu préfères on
ne demande pas l'acte de courage ils
m'adorent une m
le comique que c'est vraiment des petits
enfants et deux petits-enfants didier
jacob imagine tu as plus de pognon t'as
plus rien leur donner à manger sont
vraiment je vais les faire dans la
province nord
il faut dire que ça gimont ces pauvres
enfants pour les échanger est ce que tu
es vente de la drogue à la sortie des
écoles
zahoui pour tes enfants puissent
survivre est ce que tu le ferais ça
c'est la question qu'ont par excellence
non je préfère les landes survivre à
parler politique et pour qui a qui
trouvent tue le plus de circonstances
atténuantes staline hitler polpot bon
alors qu staline et hitler si tu
préfères ses copines je connais pas très
bien je suis rentré lequel dix ont tué
ses trois dictateurs lequel tu excuses
le plus des pros staline hitler ou paul
paul hanna reste à mais moi je vous dis
oui mais qui sont à mon goût lien
problème tu leur parles tu fais bien
c'était ça fait bientôt dans les
mémoires ouais tu penses que c'est des
psychopathes aiguisant les cinq ans et
je vous dis que les gens moi j'aurais
dit parce que ça semble pas y attacher
sortie si ça allait bien c'est mal écrit
en gras bon alors je continue
quelle race préfères-tu tu les jaunes
les blancs les noirs ou les rouges
qu'est-ce que tu préfèrerais être sourde
muette aveugle première solution
ou alors avoir les quatre membres coupés
à ras la pression sur mu est aveugle
première solution 2e et 4e mon combat
c'est que tu peux quand même regarder la
télé tu peux regarder sabatier sa
puissance
écoute je sais pas là tu vois je deviens
j'aimerais autant comme stratégie voilà
maintenant tu es seul tout seul dans un
refuge de montagne perdu à huit jours de
marches de du premier être vivant
1 et puis tu as envie de faire l'amour
ce n'est pas moi qui dans ce refuge est
alors imagine bien à ce moment-là qu'est
ce que tu préférerais faire l'amour avec
une femme avec une personne du même sexe
que toi quand tu ne pourrais pas me
voilà ou alors se masturber
[Musique]
oui c'est comment s'avère assez
consternante personnes au japon du but
avec à écouter non non non non non
alors maintenant si tu devais vraiment
toujours pas arrêtée dans le refuge
et avec un très bon ami cette fois et y
meurent de froid est-ce que tu commences
la tourette et les tourelles
est ce que tu veux qu'on serait par
contre pas manger le doigt ou les joues
charia rien à bouffer tous derrière
avoue franchement par django assez
commence par le jambon à toi moi je
commençais par la gym par l'aj auxerre
mercredi
ce que tu
préfère-t-on père ou sa mère ça c'est un
piège à rat ça c'est pas possible tu
peux pas répondre tu peux et toi non
je regarde l'émission j'ai trop
intelligente de question qu'on veut
passer pour qui tu es le plus en fait à
qui tu trouve le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
ja rule eskimos pinochet a mérité une
bourse soit parce que tu que je te dise
ok je n'ai aucun cas des circonstances
atténuantes pour pouvoir aller gens
dangereux
source de terrifiants générale je pense
qu'ils sont aussi pierre l'un que
l'autre
oui aussi grave question qu'on peut-être
plus facile maintenant si tu devais
partir sur une île déserte
tu peux faire et partir avec jospin ou
super magie non mais bon au pire des cas
malawi doit partir
bon peut-être parce que tu es socialiste
parce qu'il est mieux équipé donc on
vous parle dans les politiques par
imagine maintenant c'est la guerre une
espionne été arrêté puis on dit voilà on
va la voile a tué parce que aucun droit
d'être espion est-ce que tu préférais
être fusil guillotine et ça aussi c'est
très con question parce que coûte
la chaise électrique notre part ni de
port non physique et peut-être alors
avant fusillés pourquoi tu penses que ça
va coûter l'attend la tente se
regroupent pour faire at elle attendu en
attendant la terrible c'est pas pareil
là on est en position normale est-ce que
magie non toujours si on me disait voilà
vous rester paralysé toute votre vie
allongé sur un lit en fer en fait faire
mais il y aura plus jamais d'inondations
au bangladesh tous les petits-enfants du
bangladesh pourront manger du riz à leur
faim jusqu'à la fin des temps sacrifice
m'appelle oui
non je crois pas que j'irai jusqu'à me
sacrifier même multiples petits enfants
du bangladesh pouvait vite des frais en
pratique dans la réalité tu crois pas
que je prends dernière question
maintenant parce que de façon la bombe à
risque est ce que c'est la plus con
c'est pas les imagine que voilà un jour
tu allumes la radio un matin je
travaillais à la radio que l'on dit une
bombe atomique est parti
de quelque part dans une fusée et puis
la bombe arrive dans cinq minutes
qu'est ce que tu fais quelles sont les
dernières choses que tu fais pas ta mère
tu as fait ton frère tu tangwa en l'air
je crois que la dernière solution est la
meilleure
je sais qu'il a été
il était élu oui imagine qu'un jour le
pen fasse 51 % aux élections et qui
deviennent présente la république
oui tu préfères ça tu préfères qui est
plus d'élection pendant dix ans pour
éviter que ça arrive et est bien vrai
dire je n'aime pas d'opinion toute façon
je ne vote pas qu'est ce qui te gêne le
plus d'acheter minutes des capotes
anglaises
il ya bien sûr pourquoi ne pas ce que
c'est ça qui vous répondent non j'ai pas
du capt'ain achètent souvent n'ont
jamais t'as pas peur avec ce qui se
passe en ce moment non ah bon non
c'était très fidèle et on mario si oui
avant ça pour ça et qu'est ce qui te
dégoûte le moins l'homosexualité ou le
voyeurisme
qu'est ce qui me dégoûte les m'attend
qu'est ce qui te dégoûte le moins loin
oui si tu devais pratiquer un de ces
deux sports lequel te dégoûte le moins
l'homosexualité le voyeurisme
aucun des deux mots d'ebook rien de
dégoûtant et les trucs qui le dégoûte
quand même oui sûrement ou qu'est ce qui
te dégoûte le moins la scatophilie ou la
nécrophilie à 1-0 on les galères les
deux des oui oui dans la première fois
c'est aucun cas la deuxième fois ci les
deux si tu devais être incarné tu
préfères être incarnée en marguerite
duras - marilyn monroe
[Rires]
layton comme en france
et oui imagine qu hier matin tout la
radio tu apprends pl la bombe atomique
va tomber dans cinq minutes
festif et dans les cinq dernières
minutes qui te reste à vivre un temps
qui trompe tout envoi pas en l'air avec
ton mari en cinq minutes
imaginons par exemple vous rencontrez un
type génial le reste de votre vie
celui avec qui vous avez vraiment envie
de vous marier il est beau il est riche
et intelligent il a toutes les qualités
et il vous dit moi je viens marier avec
vous avec toi parce que tu sais trés ce
moment-là il des territoires à mais à
une condition c'est que vous auriez été
votre carrière de chanteuse de
réalisatrice d'actrice ou alors deuxième
solution vous ne rencontrez jamais cet
homme là et vous terminez votre carrière
grandement comme tout le monde peut
penser vous avez terminé
est-ce que vous choisissez alors bien
sûr je choisi la première solution a
bien sûr sacrifice sur l'autel de
l'amour ah ben oui donc les patients
peuvent se présenter
absolument deuxième question qu'on vous
devez partir sur une île déserte avec un
garçon oui est-ce que vous préféré
partir avec un blanc un jaune un noir ou
un rouge
je ne partirai pas sur une île déserte
parce que je pense que ce n'est pas
intéressant que ce n'est pas le rêve
j'ai théoriquement fait pour être le
rêve désert je ne crois pas je crois pas
que c'est quoi pour vous la meilleure
île déserte du monde alors je partirai
pour un voyage interplanétaire
bon alors avec trans galactique
j'emmènerai tous dans le vaisseau tous
une réponse à la balle on va passer une
question un peu plus un peu plus
sérieuse est ce que vous seriez prête à
donner votre vie car vous avez vous
mourriez instantanément si grâce à ça on
trouver un vaccin
un remède contre le sida attention à ce
que vous allez lire oui est coupée moi
je veux bien mourir mais par amour
alors si ça devait guérir mon fiancé du
sida oui bonne réponse
malin si vous deviez être incarné vous
croyez à l'incarnation
je n'y crois pas mais jamie croire bon
est-ce que vous préfériez est réincarné
en chien berger allemand setter
irlandais ou espagnols breton à la dure
oui si un berger allemand pourquoi parce
que comme ça j'aurai un maître qui
pourra me dresser
[Musique]
par exemple si le produit est ce que tu
préfères passé une nuit avec un mec que
tu aime à la folie
ou une semaine avec un mec que tu aimes
moyennement ça c'est vraiment une
question super coureur tu peux faire
quoi passer même une de minuit avec
monde que j'aime évidemment alors et si
tu étais obligé je pars un jour que j'ai
faite prisonnière
ouais on te dit ouais c'est une idée
comme ça tout ça un jeu alors voici les
questions
alors j'ai faite prisonnière appuyant te
dis voilà est obligé de faire l'amour
avec la personne avec qui en battant
fermés dans cette cellule je vois la
situation est ce que tu préfères faire
l'amour avec une fille ou un mec les
vraiment qui vous pousse à
l'homosexualité alors je sais pas moi
il ya des gens qu'elle a l'air non c'est
pas trop dans des sens tu préfères
d'affiché jamais essayé les films et je
crois que si j'étais obligé je préfère
encore essayé définitif à définitif ou
recevoir des legs à faire j'ai pas
encore ce public
alors maintenant question impossible à
mon sens mais certaines personnes
peuvent y répondre
est ce que tu préfères renault ou
goldman 1 2 3
je sais pas s'il ya un long silence là
tu arrives pas j'arrive pas mais si on
était sûr à mon avis c'est une question
à laquelle peugeot réponse n'a pas
besoin de règles pas de quoi vraiment
génial pour qui tuer le plus de
circonstances atténuantes à qui tu
trouve le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux mecs qui se tape des petites
filles elles font ça pour l'argent ou
alors un jeune mec qui toujours pour
l'argent tapent sur des vieilles
vraiment pas du tout court alors
euh tu as bien compris la question oui
oui maintenant j'essaie d'imaginer le
tableau est bien le plus sinon je te
demande pas de tout mettre en ordre
oui je pardonne aux jeunes tu pars de
nos jeunes qui tapent sur des vieilles
ouais parce que son pc c'est qu'il est
obligé de s'en sortir
bon il est un bon d'accord alors que
l'autre il est pas obligé de payer des
petites filles laura l'autre c'est un
pervers
si tu rentres chez toi soir avec un
garde son discours prévu qu rentrer avec
lui c'est pas ton fiancé habituel etc
c'est un garçon tu as rencontré genre la
première question coup de foudre
et puis tu as oublié quelque chose sur
la table de nuit un objet assez
compromettants sur ma table de nuit ou
et avant lui il manque six mois oui tu
le ramène chez toi fin via chez toi
bonjour gecko été oublié qu'est ce qui
te gêne le plus d'avoir oublié mind game
ou à gollnisch et
ah c'est terrible y a rien sur ma table
de nuit et tu veux pas répondre là
vraiment qu'est ce qui te gêne le plus
vis-à-vis du avec ce mec tu as envie de
te montrer vis-à-vis de lui si tu veux
tu veux montrer que tu es une fille bien
et tout qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui te gêne
le plus de vignes moi je crois que c'est
maicon d'accord mais je tenais bon
deuxièmement site était amputé d'un
membre choisit voilà vous avez tous ces
trafics
on va être obligé de vous amputé d'un
membre on est obligé toi c'est un jeu
alors le skies un bras ou une jambe un
bras
d'abord lequel le bras droit le bras
gauche de gauche évidemment je droitière
et site était maître du monde
tu ferais quoi devant ma plante
réveillant je deviens mètres du mont
femme maîtresse du monde
habilité énorme que je vais mettre du
monde et la première chose que tu fais
ce serait aider les gens mais je sais
pas comment site est maître du monde
peut faire plein de trucs mais ted qui
en première j'ai dû tout l'argent que
les prisonniers politiques déjà dans
tous les pays
ouais dans tous les pays déjà il ya du
boulot c'est beaucoup de boulot et puis
ensuite je taxe je m'appelle après les
jeux texte toutes les denrées
alimentaires stockées en en surgelé
monde entier ils envoient dans les colis
sous alimentés
parce qu'il ya des aliments stocker
ancion je dis qu'on sort pas tout
simplement parce que votre pack les prix
baissent en alimentation est ce ça me
met hors de moi alors qu'on envoie des
cartons de protéines c'est je m'en fous
si belle alors donc les maîtres du monde
qui peut tout changer
ou est-ce que tu mettrais la france sur
la carte du monde tu pouvais choisir tu
la sens bien je la mets laxiste une âme
est resté uni faisait le co2 ccs en
partie parce qu'une grande polynésie
quoi dans le temps entre les palmiers
troyes et paris tu le mets très haut par
rapport à ça
la pari bien situé salvat oui je mettrai
pas à cannes par hasard et ben non non
non je te parlais bien situé
dernière question con je te dis la bombe
arrive dans cinq minutes
la bombe atomique ouais elle va tomber
sur paris qu'il en soit la concorde
qu'est ce que tu fais dans les cinq
dernières minutes
je vais t'aider je sais pas écouté mon
fiancé la proximité je me jette dans ses
bras toute sa lucidité là nous on a dû
polémique quand même mais je crois qu'un
mac y réagiraient production mais je
crois que c'est dans un moment par
ailleurs de la besoin surtout de se
sentir va se sentir seule fois collé
contre lui tu attends de 50 points
je fais pas une prière par hasard donc
pour l'au delà
ouais pas où j'en étais sûr la noce call
of
je ne sais pas du tout répondent à ces
prêts est arrivé oui à quel point j'ai
envie questions j'imagine que tu partes
dans un vaisseau spatial à mon avis la
télé ce soir tu es bon là tu pars dans
un vaisseau spatial sur mars
quatre ans
puis y ait quatre en douceur tu as le
choix d'une bp qui tu choisis dorothée
ou chantal goya
pigé dorothée alors toujours le vaisseau
spatial ouais là il y avait là il ya
plus de pépé qu'est ce tu préfères un
mec ou la main gauche
la main gauche et des maladresses qui
rappelle celle d'une main étrangère je
reconnais mais que tu préfères le mec
pour quatre ans dans le vaisseau spatial
qui va faire le mec comme away bon
maintenant autre histoire tu rencontres
une fille le coup de foudre énorme tu la
ramènes chez toi le premier soir ça
marche aussi sublime
qu'est ce qui te gêne le plus qu'elle se
sublimer sûrement le plus moche de
maison qu'est-ce que tu qu'est ce que
qu'il devienne le plus de pas bander ou
d'appeler sophie je t'aime alors qu'elle
s'appelle christ il veut dire je t'aime
qu'à une pulsion à dire suis dit je
t'aime fait signer qu'elle s'affaisse
office en marron sinon oui mais elle
pardonné fuyaient sur moi pour prime
abord mon surmoi contenu
what a dit françois cette gêne pas quoi
elle me répétant chaque fois jusqu'à ce
que je dis je pense alors imagine qu'en
deux cents ans après la terreur
recommence et on décide de
de tuer tous les partisans du roi tu
préfère mourir comment fusillés ou
guillotiné
je pense pas que je pense pas que je
fais une victime l'acquéreur dont je
crois pas tu pour vimy l'année autre
alarme yoann on imagine que tu sois mort
quand même et que tu sois réincarner tu
préfères être incarné ans christine
ockrent ou ppda peuplé d abord pourquoi
pas que sina com ottavi chaperon rouge
alors imagine qu'en 89 la terreur ne
recommence pas tout se passe bien et
juste des commémorations mais que toi
par contre on propose un dit on dit
voilà philippe léotard ou louerait
instantanément mais grâce à ça on va
trouver un vaccin pour soigner tous les
gens qui ont le sida
qu'est-ce que tu préfère mourir on
trouve jamais de lacs sont toujours durs
au sida j'ai rencontrés ils sont tous
très sympathiques mais ils ont plus de
risques de leur fournit aux autres et
donc je suis pas sûr que j'ai juste
réalisé taxi alors dis-moi tu
préfèrerais vivre dans un pays libre
mais très très très très très pauvres ou
dans une dictature où il ya un très très
très haut niveau dit par exemple je
préférais de pauvres dans un pays où tu
préfères être pauvre dans un pays libre
que non je suis quoi l'accord imagine
que tu que tu es un milliard demi
hier deux milliards temps frais quoi
mais bolt ouais ok mais moyens ouais
tabak
ouais alcool ouais et elle sera encore
des milliards de milliards jetés avant
goethe et hubert et fine campagne
électorale à ton frère part ils ont
elles pu crever la gueule ouverte sur l
affaire je tairai pas des campagnes
électorales à personne se trouve c'est
du gaspillage ayachi je lui ai dit le
premier dit et si j'avais moi un solo de
mon frère à grand chose
ouais
est ce que tu peux faire et avoir un
père c'est là où l'autre à france inter
qui soit très absent qui convoie jamais
que jamais la queue très occupé mais
qu'un ministre ou un père qui est
toujours la ksk une super bien de toi
mais moi je viens d'avoir un outil
magnifique
tous étaient contents de le faire alors
donc ce qui compte c'est qu'il soit
parce que du coup quand un papa qui est
heureux il renverra c'est bien géré les
parents vis du salaison ses sous non
c'est bien d'avoir un père heureux c'est
tout bon donc tu préfère qu'il soit
absent même famille mais non mais toute
façon plus tu sais l'absence est pas une
histoire de temps mais si tu sens que tu
es ok tu vois qu'il va bien quand tu
sens que quelqu'un t'aime moi non si tu
ne vois pas est ce le fait que tu saches
effets personnels des contacts avant de
s'y fier alors tes activités de fait
quoi en ce moment j'écoute en ce moment
j'aimerais m'occuper de la distribution
d'un journal
d'ailleurs c'est un scout qui va sortir
en mars 81 à un journal que fait par
robert maxwell qui s'appelle laurent t1
ouais un journal qui va être distribué
sur toute l'europe
c'est le premier journal européen et le
premier premier demander des journées
d'échangés quotidiens européens
est-ce que tu préférerais être très
reconnue de ton vivant que tu deviennes
de ton vivant une super patronne de
presse ou une surface que tu veux tu
très reconnu dans tous les journaux
toutes les télés bon et puis quand tu
meurs tu complètement oublié ou alors
est-ce que tu préfère ne pas être connu
du tout de ton vivant et une fois que tu
es morte je peux peut-être 50 ans après
tu est reconnu comme un des grands
génies du mal
je préfère la reconnaissance posthume
c'est ce tu préfères être connu 50 ans
après comme un des grands génies du
manic 2 soit je voudrais pouvoir
apporter des choses maintenant
ouais au monde avec ce que je sais faire
si je sais faire des choses et puis
éventuellement faire partie de ce qui
peut faire progresser dans mon boulot
donc après ma mort toute façon je m'en
fous parce que tu serais prête à mourir
là comme ça voilà oui si d'un seul coup
tous les petits éthiopien pouvez manger
à leur faim
mais c'est absurde qu'une question
d'annoncer qu'ils ont vus mais c'est
comme ça c'est le jeu que j'aime c'est à
je peux pas très pour du beurre
instantanément
oui et puis tu sais que pendant tout le
temps en ethiopie en plein de blé plein
de messages tu crois la réincarnation
je ne sais pas mais je crois en l'au
delà je considère incarne emma je crois
que j'y crois c'est est choqué c'est
l'histoire de scorsese de profondeur
c'est pas digne de les venger
non c'est bien c'est pas une question de
ça c'est que le christ a enseigné aimez
vous les a mises entre ap et qu' il a
justement enseigner la différence qu'il
fallait respecter les différences dans
justement on parle de la tentation du
christ précisément je me souviens parce
que j'ai relu justement à propos de ce
scandale
vous imaginez dans l'évangile de saint
matthieu dieu de dia le temps trois fois
le christ dans le désert
et comme dix autres grands mystiques la
plus grave tentation c'est pas la
tentation la chasse et la tentation de
l'esprit et justement dans les temps les
évangiles à la tentation de la chair
mais à la tentation d'esprit du pouvoir
choses plus de poser ma question qu'on
va près tout ce que tu dis bien si loin
et donc tout ce que font ses jambes qui
permet jeudi qu'il interdise les autres
interprétations s'ils allaient à
l'encontre même de la parole du christ
non si tu étais réincarner est-ce que tu
préférais réincarné en marylin monroe ou
marguerite duras marilyn monroe
abo alors imagine maintenant ta mère
rentre dans ta chambre par hasard arrivé
doit taper mon père imaginez-le rente
elle ouvre la porte elle peut lui
arriver
qu'est ce qui te fait le plus honte qui
est un mec dans ma chambre qui est deux
mecs ou une fille est donc être ce qui
te fait le plus long oui bon je fais
avec une fille tu préfères qu'elle te
vois avec deux mecs avec une fille mais
j'ai fini à qui tu trouve le plus de
circonstances atténuantes hitler staline
ou polpot personnes au cas est entre la
rue les skis et pinochet
c'est plus compliqué là je crois que
pinochet qui ne fait vraiment pas donc
je trouve plus de circonstances
atténuantes à ja rule skis cas pinochet
croire en plus différents tu sais c'est
trop ce serait trop longue date lors
pourquoi voir mais j'avais jésus-christ
aujourd'hui les évangiles
bon alors dernière question cette fois
ci tu étais maîtres du monde
la maîtresse du monde on trouve ensuite
été dieu désemplit pas si tu es bien de
moi j'adore les mythiques si tu étais
dieu pour san pour cinq minutes disant
tu mettrais la france ou sur la
mappemonde la royale je laisserai où
elle est parce que les choses sont là où
elles sont si on a choisi des médecins
s'ils vont bien leur statut la mettrais
pas dans le pacifique où en sont les
héros
imagine que tu dois partir pour un
voyage dans l'espace est-ce que tu
prendrais la navette russe où la navette
américaine
écoute je prendrai avec 13 sur la dette
oui ils ont fait sept morts et deux
disparus
c'est donc c'est la navette américaine
alors maintenant tu dois partir dans la
bête tu sais que tu as passé quatre ans
pour arriver sur marc est ce que tu
préfères partir avec une jolie fille ou
un mec les s'il n'y a pas d'autres
équipages interdit tout de suite
tu préfères partie avec tellement attend
parolier quand même pour s'avancer
malgré une chanson we cas ça sera une
jolie fille avec une jolie fille
donc tu as un peu satisfaite dérange pas
de passer quatre ans avec une conclusion
que les gens tireront les conclusions
alors est-ce que la fille qui préféré
qu'elle soit blanche noire jaune ou
rouge arc en ciel ont pour voir qu en
ciel c'est peut-être roulante est obligé
de faire l'amour avec un mac c'est un
jeu c'est un juif allemand avec un
vainqueur à choisir entre deux mètres tu
préfères qui geste pas aux jupes et
intérêts comme question est les deux à
la faune potable et de la porte
al'inverse on te dit voilà maintenant
vous avez le choix pendant les dix
prochaines années soit vous n'avez plus
de sexe du tout c'est quand même pas le
droit de ne même pas la fille de la
navette spatiale même s'ils n'ont pas
prêt à les attacher oui enfin je vois
pas de sexe pendant dix ans c'est
hallucinant et puma non non non tu ne
peux pas le faire ajoute même toi même
toi même toit mais bon c'est sa première
solution ou deuxième solution tu ne
manges plupart en disant c'est à dire
nourris avec des dés sont des piqûres de
machin des trucs qu est ce que tu
préfère ne pas avoir de s'être fait
avoir de bouffe pendant dix ans dimanche
pendant dix ans et avoir la portée mais
tom a nommé l'on écoute alors que ses
deux ferries dont m de toute façon dans
ma tête il se passe tellement choses
mieux qu'en vrai je peux te dire pendant
dix ans je suis dans ma tête pendant
toute la saison
en tout cas avec lui sur l'île déserte
arrive à roissy il ya le douanier couche
ta valise 1 qu'est ce qui te gêne le
plus qu'ils trouvent à l'intérieur de la
balise mein kampf ou un godemiché rien
du tout alors il peut tomber ce qu'il
veut des tonnes de de capotes usagers ou
pas mannequin pour un emplacement
comptera alors les douaniers parce qu'on
est ce qu'ils veulent avant tout les ans
m'a l'air vraiment les emmerdes
même s'ils sont antillais mais j'adore
les sentiers pour fumer un pétard à la
maison un corps m'a dit cet imac te
trompes tu t'aperçois qui trompe qu'est
ce que tu préfères comme vengeance lui
puis crevé les yeux avec une perceuse
électrique
ou alors lui transmet le sexe avec une
tronçonneuse électrique équipée d'un
témoin qu'il avait bien sûr
il a fallu écouter ce n'est pas parce
que parce que vraiment eu crève les yeux
avec une personne que les transcende le
sexe et qu'une personne n'en avait que
je pense qu'en fait les tronçonneuses
mais alors vraiment je pense que je sois
beaucoup plus qu'on colle ça à bord mais
je pense que j'irai là-bas détresse moi
je pense pas avoir volé sa maîtresse je
pense que ce serait vraiment la plus
grande des banques
c'est une bonne réponse était pas
vraiment bouddhiste enfin je veux dire
bon tu as quand même flirter avec le
bouddhisme et tu crois la vainqueure
nation oui bon alors si tu étais un
carnet ce que tu préfères être incarnée
en jean jean pierre foucault
patrick sabatier où ils chialent drucker
heureusement que tu peux pas citer parce
qu'alors vraiment aurait-il de mais en
tout cas tout moi je pense pas comprise
comme ça des cendres de conditions moi
je la prochaine elisabeth taylor jeune
maman
ça va leur faire plaisir mais entre les
trois tout cela répondrait entre
sabatier drucker il faut qu on a bien le
gym se soit obligatoire c'est un jeu
mais coup d'essai en plus moi j'ai de la
tendresse pour l'e3 est plus particulier
une particulièrement pour sabatier trop
cher et plus de dix mille euros c'est
sûr à temps et c'était ce que je ne sais
pas la tt legends des jeux
alors maintenant la bombe arrive dans 5
minutes ou la radio à matin tech ta
fille tombe à arriver tous les trois la
maison abritant mais c'est la vie on te
dit la bombe va tomber dans cinq minutes
qu'est ce que tu fais pendant les cinq
dernières minutes comme disait
l'inspecteur borel je prie c'est bien
qu'ils trouvent toi et moi j'aurai moi
j'aimerais être n ya pas de prix c'est
un choix entre sauver ta fille autant
marie tu sauves quoi merci
pourtant avec ton mari tu préfères
d'autres filles c'est simple tu sauf
quand même ta fille sur imaginé première
question premier répond christian conte
avec tous les deux moi je la pose au
delà enfin s'arrête concerne la première
je pense qu'elle te consomme un peu plus
toi c'est à dire que
un jour je décide de faire un enfant et
puis tu t'aperçois que tu peux plus en
avoir pour des raisons tu peux plus en
avoir
et tu cherches une mère porteuse et
mireille mathieu te propose d'être ta
mère porteuse est ce que tu acceptes
parce que tu refuses d'abord je vais
faire un test et de glucides a dit oui
oui sinon oui mais pas de problème
non non pourquoi non je sais pas je te
demande c'est une question
deuxième question est à toi si tu veux
c'est vrai quoi cette correspondante
être un peu mieux aussi à qui se trouve
le plus de circonstances atténuantes à
un vieux qui se tape des petits garçons
pour de l'argent ou un petit garçon qui
tapent sur des vieux toujours pour de
l'argent
au sein au cas aucun des circonstances
atténuantes suis très moral finalement
poids 1
et toi c'est lui qui réfléchit pas
d'accord j'ai compris alors à toi
maintenant d'accord est-ce que tu serais
prêt à mourir maintenant la connaissance
subitement grande carrière fini
nettement pour que l'apartheid soit
immédiatement supprimées en afrique du
sud
non pas que c'est là l'autre jour tu as
posé une question si la faim dans le
monde en prenant le dis moi pour me
deprez tellement bien sûr on peut le
faire à lombez pour des trucs qui sont
là toute la planète assure pas là pour
un pénis à vos balcons
ça va faire plaisir aux 12 alors
imaginez tous les looks dans un chalet
pourtant c'est bien qu'on ait vous êtes
tous les deux ans dans un chalet de
montagne puis lui les morts m et puis
toi t'as rien n'est tabou fait je me
mange mais tu commences par konrad sioui
d'accord mais tu commences parfois assez
ça avec moi sortir pour boucler la mère
fait quoi que je suis dans la tête parce
que comme ça au moins je le verrais plus
la cervelle non la figure au nom peu
près qu'une bonne petite soeur élise oui
parce qu'on voit gribiche debbiche
bon vous êtes morts tous les sports tous
les deux vous préfet trinquet stone et
charden yoko et john ou pierre et marie
curie pierre et marie curie bah ouais
pourquoi l'attachement sérieux en fait
yoko
bon alors question qu'on traditionnel la
bande arrive dans le cinq minutes que
c'était moi je me tapais inverse de jack
daniel's puis je faire un grand baie à 4
et puis voilà tu sais toi catherine
droit d'avoir le baiser au jaï alaï pour
l'année parce que la ligne vous avez une
solution de vous échapper
juste avant d'arriver à aberdeen vous
appelle vous écouter les gens comme
alessi crouch la bombe
on vous met dans un vaisseau spatial
nous cacher des sur la lune ou sur mars
marchait pas ou là où c'est bien toi là
où il n'y a pas de bombe mais il ya
trois places dans le vaisseau spatial et
comme verdi les bons ils nous ont pris
un troisième passager renault fut bien
faire ou non google manon ppda guy lux
ou sabatier france a battu et je crois à
bon oui pourquoi guy lux il arrête pas
de il est trop tôt et oui les jeux vidéo
est trop sérieux saint-mathieu harfang
darabont se joue du xylophone le sourire
les pilotes d'avion invasion invisible
fameux avion invisible américain qui
transporte la bombe atomique
puis d'un seul coup tu es en l'air et
puis ne manche à balai et demi où tu
peux plus le diriger cet avion et tu vas
tu écrasé états comme le choix de
t'écraser soit sur new york soit sur
moscou où tu t'écrases aux questions
qu'on a très con alex contre je n'ai je
peux mais je peux pas dire comme il en a
c'est en ça que c'est con mais c'est
très content et genre tu préfères ton
père ou ta main je suis obligé de
répondre un tu es obligé de répondre
lecture moscou alors à bon ben voilà une
réponse coudre au hasard je vois toute
façon si tu ne mourrait tu préfères être
incarné ans marguerite duras ou en
marilyn monroe
ouh ah bon oui tu préfères la beauté que
l'intelligence mais il n'y rien ne
prouve qu'elle est et qu'on imagine ton
mec tu te trompes d'un jeu qu'est ce que
tu fais tu lui perce les yeux à perceuse
électrique nuit le couple le sexe à la
tronçonneuse et à millas ni l'autre
qu'est ce tu fais je le dois de mon
mépris
ouais je plus absolu c'est tout
combien les champs c'est un méchant je
serai plus gêné s'y trouvait au lit avec
un autre mec ou avec deux filles
[Rires]
c'est une vertu
je serai ce serait très gêné s'il
trouvait avec d'aussi bon moi je vous
dirais je trouve avec un look make way
ce serait plus normal
et toi c'était obligé de faire l'amour
obligé sous la sous la menace d'une arme
tu préfères et le faire avec une jolie
fille vrai qu'avec les carnets québec
ah bon oui les filles ça te nonce
apostolique pour coucher avec ça
m'intéresse pas vraiment toujours dans
la série amour obligatoires tu es obligé
qui préfèrent faire l'amour avec bar
giscard ou chirac
oui mon voyage dure question à baron
fait jamais bon d'être séparée jsk il
est pas mal et chirac n'est pas mal mais
il faut choisir le président a été
obligé de choisir
eh ben
ce quart alors ah bon ouais plaisir
alors imagine que tu adoptes des enfants
qui préférait adopter des jumeaux
cleptomane des jumelles pyromanes c'est
merveilleux ces questions oui c'est le
vampire attend alors deux jumelles
pyromane ou deux jumeaux cape town a
exactement
t'écoutes que c'est plus rigolo les
jumeaux keith bowman parce qu au moins
ils ramèneront des trucages
est-ce que tu serais prêt à mourir à
prête à mourir pour qu'il n'y ait plus
jamais de chômeurs en france
non tu meurs tout de suite ah non non je
suis pas prête
pourquoi toi c'est toi papa tabouret
pour les plus jeunes pourquoi tu es
prête à mourir par exemple ok plus
jamais l'inondation bangladesh tes
pattes à mourir je suis pas prête et je
suis prête à mourir pour rien du tout
rien du tout non plus même si à plus
jamais de pauvres sur la terre pendant
des siècles démission il faut que ça
aille très vite alors ce qui dégoûte le
plus c'est la scatophilie la nécrophilie
alors la scatophilie c'est quoi ces gens
qui mangent d'aider les choses
dégoûtantes et la nécrophilie c'est des
gens qui mangent jean marc bouche des
cadavres c'est ce qui les excite si tu
veux cette manche d'état leur a alors
créé sculpté à la nécrophilie au mois
frais de la viande rouge d'abord morte
alors ah bon oui nous allons mais tu
réponds c'est bien donc c'est la
microphysique tu préfère manger un
cadavre que manger des excréments
parce que si je mourais de faim par
exemple je mangerais bien un cadavre je
mange crois pas que je mangerai des
choses dernière question con tu pars sur
un vaisseau spatial pour un voyage qu'il
a duré à peu près 4 50 voix si l'on est
tu peux amener un seul passage et enfin
le client c'est une passagère est ce que
tu nous as oui tu préfères
france gall ou catherine là à moi je
connais mieux catherine lara france gall
je crois que j'aimerais mieux katrina
jeu contre hitler ça risque de mal se
passer louis latapie
ah bon je croyais que j'aimais ce type
toi aussi je me dis attention
non mais ce qu'on se marre bien avec
catherine je ne dis pas qu'on se marre
pas bien avec france que je la connais
tous moins bien donc c'est catherine
lara pendant quatre ans en quatre ans
avec un peut-être un mayer
jean par exemple que tu partes sur un
vaisseau spatial oui dans la pompe
quatre ont quand même s'ils ont assez
long j'espère que tu vas bien entouré
aaaaah france gall ou véronique sanson
je prendrais verrou écoute
elle l'a dit ouah ah bon ouais sont
d'ailleurs tu vois donc on est d'accord
pour partir toutes les deux oui mais
sauf qu'elle a dit qu'elle prendrait un
petit
mallet pour se protéger mais hier à la
soirée voyage elle a dit c'est pas quand
j'aurai mon cas j'aurais mon petit ici à
la liste un moment avec elle je suis sûr
de m'éclater
je connais bien françois mitterrand ttt
pote avec lui et moi c'est le cas de le
dire
françois mitterrand bon un jour il
demande y est comme ça j'aimerais bien
que vous trouviez une maîtresse
alors est-ce que tu préfèrerais tu vas
qui tue qui tue contacterait simone veil
cette panne arlette laguiller ou jean
paul briat à moi je me revois brialy ce
sera plus drôle jeu télé le plus con
jeter les locaux je vais t'en citer 2 tu
vas me dire lequel est le plus bête j'ai
presque fait gaffe sont très cons tous
les deux le juste prix assez bien s'en
douter les magots réfléchit bien ah oui
et c'est du juste prix me semble très
très fort encore encore plus compétents
que prévu mais c'est bon tout le monde
dit juste prix je serai ça me fait
réfléchir
imagine que tu puisses faire interdire
quelqu'un de télévision
féministe de la culture oui tu peux
faire interdire quelqu'un télévision
est-ce que tu ferais interdite sébastien
ou seb était légale mais c'est terrible
c'est terrible ça des artistes passent
nouveau tous les deux dès 20h30 va être
obligé de te fâcher avec l'un ou avec
l'autre
ou alors d'esquiver la question
ce qui ne serait pas très honnête non
mais j'ai pas envie de vivre ont tout
seul sans toi ça va c'est mme harel 25
est d'accord alors maintenant on va
passer au conte sentiment contraire
un jour je sais pas tu vas encore plus
de disques d'habitude et puis multi
quand même là je m'aime beaucoup
d'argent je vais faire un grand bonheur
est-ce que cet argent tu préfèrerais le
donner à des petits noirs de soweto ou à
des petites palestiniens de gaza a cédé
question pencher plus con tu meurs là
casam ce n'est pas choisir
je verrai où les petits blackie
d'afrique du sud où les petits
palestiniens de palestine
on sait rien
en afrique du sud en afrique du sud sur
les patients du temps mais je m'en fous
pas peur je fasse un choix
parce que oui je me rattraperai une
autre fois l'an dernière question la
pire de toutes
peut-être oui 287 et 129
ça fait combien 287 et 129 ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup de millions pour vous
conduire c'est qu'à ce prix allaient
baisser
c'est ce que j'apprécie c'est je retiens
rien 289 et 122 187
416 2
[Applaudissements]
par exemple imagine que tu puisses avoir
quelque chose en plus en plus en plus tu
peux faire ma avoir donné 200 3 où je
crois que jacques préféré que j'ai deux
sexes de ces imagine que tu sois
enceinte de nouveau oui chance sur un
plaisir tu fais une échographie et on te
dit voilà votre petit
mais il a deux sexes il a donné où il a
trois yeux qu'est ce que tu ferais tu te
feras avorter ou tulle garderait parce
que finalement ces cas là c'est comme ça
je regarderai pas tu viendrais pas tu
fais comme hitler alors dire que tu te
tue les gens qui sont pas normaux qua
non mais je crois qu'en ce moment on
allait les moyens d'empêcher un être
d'avoir une vie vraiment défavorisés je
trouve qu'il faut utiliser ses moyens
tu rentres chez toi sois et tu trouves
jacques dutronc au lit avec isabelle
adjani mais temps où tu appelles paris
match je me joins à eux ils médias le
tueur à mr design je n'ai rien contre
les amours saphiques alors salaires dans
ces conditions la wii avec isabelle
adjani ça va oui oui la condition
vous séparer avec jacques ça c'est
triste ou séparé le pauvre thomas il se
retrouve tout seul
pourquoi ça tout seul si on se sépare
toi aussi enfin pour tout le monde ceci
étant il faut le confier à quelqu'un
c'est un jeu est-ce que tu préférais
qu'il soit confié à karen cheryl à
chantal goya ou à dorothée ça s'est
interrogé sur wii un dilemme avant tout
à fait crever je ne sais pas du tout je
sais déjà que toi sale mère nourricière
à qui voudrait qu'il soit confié je
crois je confie à chantal goya parce que
c'est la seule que je connaisse des
temps c'est la seule qui ait des enfants
ouais enfin sa vie à la télé en plus
chantal goya dont qu'elle s'occuperait
du moment c'est pour ça enfin je crois
qu'il faudrait surtout venant des
invités marleau qui rentre ah bon je
crois qu'il préférait se passer
maintenant je vais poser une question
encore plus con si c'est possible
tu es prisonnière et les gens qui te
tiennent comme ça géôliers t'oblige à
faire l'amour avec un animal dérive
s'est jamais pensé non ça jamais tu vas
y penser pour la première fois ce soir
il était temps à ton âge est ce que tu
préférerais un cochon est un cochon
verra mon cochon un chien ouanaminthe où
tu entends tu veux réfléchir on a le
temps là vraiment c'est là c'est quand
même moins bien qu isabelle adjani a
bruissé autre chose que la ville réserve
à globo
c'est pas j'aime beaucoup les ânes moi
je trouve ça très bien avant je prendrai
la briche pour moi c'est bien c'est les
accords vous avez appelé radio rwanda
alors maintenant si tu devais dîner avec
quelqu'un t'a pas le choix j'ai été
obligé de dîner avec lui pas d'autre
solution
tu préfèrerais dîner avec un sourd muet
ou avec un aveugle bègles gj bien
la vague le mec mais ce que je pourrais
partir en dernière question con
françoise hardy oui quelle famille c'est
une question à l'ajax
si tu avais le choix c'est pour faire
l'amour bien entendu entre une fille
très très très jolie ou un mec très laid
tu choisirais quoi bon mais il faut
répondre oui ou non comme ça dépend de
la fille jeudi où le mec là est
peut-être qu'il est très intelligent
donc ya pas de hasard
je prendrai mac alors oui parce que pas
vraiment film non mais c'est vrai a
déclaré d'ailleurs une fois je me
souviens on dit toujours que j'aime les
femmes et les fous et en fait je fais
les cas là à mon jules oui oui oui
non je prendrai le bâcler quoi a priori
oui a priori le mac n'est voilà
définitif oui oui alors imagine que ton
mec t'es pas touché pendant quinze jours
malgré des remarques persistante
tu lui as fait sentir que effectivement
pourrait s'intéresser un peu à toi
qu'est-ce que tu ferais tu regardes ton
carnet de téléphone en dix ans cherchant
à un autre mec tu te jette sur lui comme
ça violemment un soir dans la salle de
bain pendant qu'il se lave les dents
dans sa robe de chambre
ou alors vous alors tu engages à
détective privé pour savoir avec qui
trompe pas être coûteux refaire dans
l'ordre alors alors je vais jette sur
lui d'abord d'abord ahmed accords du
jazz mais comment ça se passerait pas
atteint je sais pas j'en fais une idée
mais je serais parti se lave les dents
par exemple c'est à dire que oui je
profiterai l'a déjà une main occupée
l'autriche tient sur le bord du lac mais
on s'est discrètement bon dans le miroir
commencer par le bas imagine que tu en
arrives à la troisième solution parce
que les deux premières n'ont pas marché
ce détective privé te dis
je suis désolé nous 30 madame a qu'est
ce que tu fais est ce que tu lui
couperait le sexe avec une tronçonneuse
savez question oui tout de suite
hamels a permis mais tu lui tranche le
sexe avec une hausse non tu perces le
coeur avec une perceuse
ça fait déjà plus sportivement tu me
tire une balle dans la nuque comme un
chien mais non mais je dis comptera
j'essaie de charme et la fille puis à la
limite je peux peut-être le faire pour
une fois la fille ah tu reviens sur ce
que tu as dit que tu as oui mais ça
dépend des circonstances car si tu te
fais un film pas pourquoi pas enfin
j'essaye les rapports tu sais que
antennes de la direction d'antenne
d'affaires américaine on n'est jamais
censuré sauf qu un certain nombre de
remarques pour déterrer pour votre
addiction très bien tout ça mais il faut
arrêter de parler de nécrophilie à
l'antenne c'est un truc
bon alors on va parler d'eux au phillips
que ça et me l'ont pas dit très bien
c'est bien oui alors tu as le choix
n'est obligé de faire l'amour avec un
animal obligé t'as pas le choix qui dira
c'est comme ça est-ce que tu avec un
chien car la brader ses jolies des
labradors annoncé le labrador terme
c'est un jeu est-ce que tu préférais le
labrador de giscard au labrador de
mitterrand j'ai deux réponses n'ont pas
jamais le jamais le labrador un chien
chien a chanté pour le clip sur
l'arménie parce que tellement de gens je
sais pas si je t'écoute c'est très
gentil mais
on en a parlé c'est ça s'est arrêté là
le rapport j'aurais pas dit non doit y
avoir un truc qui s'en occupent y
remédier et puis toute façon on peut
très bien participer ces fermiers
éthiopiens ils entendent jamais ce qu'on
fait pour eux alors imagine mal un côté
plein de thunes plein de thunes est-ce
que tu préfèrerais donner ton argent aux
pauvres arméniens ou pause ethiopia ça
c'est toujours une ambassade est
question concernent pas de réponse
qu'est-ce qu'il faut vraiment répondre
leur beurre je les pauvres arméniens qui
sont sous les décombres file encore
qu'ils sont vivants paraît-il où les
pauvres éthiopien comme rennes à manger
je sais c'est dur c'est à dire aux trois
mêmes mois j'en envoie des tous les
côtés non non ça non j'ai pas loin ça
marche
les arméniens nous étions elle demande à
son groupe
alors voilà une réponse oui tu vois je
alors maintenant est ce que tu préfères
d'ailleurs mais c'est très très con est
ce que tu préférais mourir comme john
lennon parle de mort de stars la nuit et
là est-ce que tu préférais mourir comme
john lennon c'est à dire une balle dans
le ventre
tu vois est ce que tu pourrais me faire
mourir comme janis joplin d'une overdose
ou comme le chanteur décide ici est mort
le policier tout fait dans son vomi d'où
tu préfères la balle devant devant bon
bah écoute
avis aux amateurs
était morte avant comme je les donne
mais tu as vu il ya une émission sublime
sur la mort après oui à problèmes à la
façon c'est un problème voilà alors est
ce que maintenant tu vas être réincarné
donc tu crois la réincarnation de samedi
croyons au rayon des deux minutes est-ce
que tu préférais être réincarné en fer à
repasser en machine à laver ou un
aspirateur été obligé de réponse ça fait
pas fausse individus non non non non la
chasse en plaine moi j'ai ris de veau
callas pouvant alors ça c'est pas
possible on fait un brin ses caisses du
mahdi aspirateur machine à laver tout
simplement en fer à repasser
tu préfères parce que ça fait des
caresses aux gens d'abord parce que ça
peut être doux et ça peut être une vraie
sarah longtemps dans les comptes ils
aspirent les conneries toute la journée
l'eau qui la vraie connerie des mois
voilà donc le faire à ma place et bras
imagine deux minutes que tu prend du
temps il faut toujours dits magiques de
baisse et là je parle pas on imagine
c'est ainsi qu'est ce que tu reproches
ray le plus ça du tout allons-y tout
prenant des exemples précis
est ce que tu veux reprocherait d'avoir
mis au monde finalement
rika zaraï linda de suza oui marie
france cuba da qui est pas mal non plus
je te la conseil est obligé la normale à
tout le monde non mais c'est des
questions auxquelles tout le monde
répond ça irait pas beau tout le monde
répond alors je répète marie france cuba
da
linda de suza rika zaraï qu'est ce que
tu reproches de plus au bon dieu d'avoir
mis sur terre non mais non mais je ne
reproche pas ça se rapproche des trucs
bien pire cote a ensuite eu assez grave
at on vraiment à l'étroit que je cavale
mais c'est pas n'importe quoi je les ai
choisi exprès
ah là là mais c'est emmerdant des
troubles semblent absents bien surtout
quand un seul coup les trois du fret est
humble où tu vois j'en sais rien tu lui
reproches les trois en bloc au bruit
tant qu'acquéreur mis sur terre les
trois pages voilà comme ça qu'est ce que
tu sois j'ai pas de jalouse là tu fais
pas de gel sont à l'étroit dans le même
sac mais alors imaginons maintenant que
tu survol l'angleterre en avion bon bien
sûr tu en conviendras les deux moteurs
les moteurs sont en feu à l'avion va
tomber parce que tout avion survolant
angleterre c'est un principe à les deux
moteurs en fait un acteur et c'est là
qu'on voit qu'il a inventé ça est tous
d'accord
donc tu es dans ce que jamais du coup
vous êtes trois avions seulement
oui il ya deux parachutes
alors bon tambourin à bon bah oui non
mais attends qui sait les deux autres
trucs est riche en sel n'ont pas l'air
est plus prête mentalement d'accord donc
tu donnes les parachutes à drucker tout
tu t'es bien joli parachute je
m'accrochais drucker par là tu fais bien
ton business que tu files les parachutes
aux gens qui ont des émissions de télé
qu'est ce tu veux et c'est non mais
c'est bien quand tu fais tu peux pas ton
cou en fait c'est plutôt drucker quand
même tu choisis le mec à 20h30 tous les
samedis non mais non ce n'est pas un
roman mais non c'est pas une histoire de
20h30 c'était plutôt une histoire
d'argent
non bon alors ce n'est pas son couloir
menant dernière question c'est une
tradition si tu veux dans cette émission
c'est le vaisseau spatial tu dois partir
dans un vaisseau spatial
non parce que c'est une histoire qui
dure d'émission en émission il va partir
dans un vaisseau spatial et tu peux
choisir sur ces quatre ans le saut
spécial c'est pas de la rigolade c'est
80 que la même personne d'un couteau
servir à rien en apesanteur pendant
quatre ans avec la même personne
barak après les muscles ah oui tu vas
voir dersoir équité 1 est ce que tu
préfères partir attention on décolle
avec france gall lara catherine lara oui
véronique sanson à 7,3 mais oui c'est un
jeu irak et l monopoly c'est la rue de
la paix depuis des siècles c'est à dire
tu dois en choisir une des trois et on
est que toutes les deux pendant quatre
ans la pesanteur je te souhaite bien des
catholiques est que toutes les deux
laquelle tu choisis première expérience
mais la rage parce que c'est ensemble a
choisi la raho s'il est battu voir elle
a dit qu'elle prendra un petit maillot
oui je sais où enfin bon toi tu couteau
comme ton couteau et ben tu vois je
m'étais bien mais moi je crois que je
suis pas forcément complètement quand
c'est mieux quelqu'un qui offre un peu
d'apprentissage
voilà lancés alors dont la france a
priori non
véronique nonon dont catherine la wii
des gens d'expérience et en large du un
truc
et
imagine que tu sois surprise au lit un
jour comme ça chez toi ou dans un hôtel
à l'improviste par le père du petit
maxime olive arrêté surprise à cannes
avec eric quelqu'un d'autre qu'est ce
que c'est qu'il serait le plus sombre
c'est d'être surpris avec deux mecs ou
avec une fille et maintenant tu federer
rejoindrait alors j'espère qu'il serait
j'ai pas ça n'est jamais arrivé mais
même si ces deux mecs moi qui te
rejoindrait n'ont peut-être pas c'est
plus si c'était de créer un pour une
fille
il ment facettes je n'aurai pas beaucoup
apparemment je suis prête à tout pour ^
^ katla qui croient dans l'incarnation
papa qu'elle incarne
oui
est ce que tu préfères être réincarné en
frédéric françois
avec ta maison de disques il faut le
dire ne pas les condamner
frédéric françois ou ans françois valéry
j'avoue que c'est terrible j'avoue qu'il
vaut mieux pas sera incarné ces frappes
je prendrai quand même françois valéry
moi personnellement fassent tuer c'est
vraiment non pas que je les connais pas
toujours des copies je les connais reste
est pas particulièrement
tu sais pas pourquoi parce qu'il ne
représente pas vraiment le mal dans
toute sa splendeur
est-ce que tu serais prête à mourir
comme ça là maintenant sur le champ pour
que tous les enfants du monde soit là
pour qu'ils aient plus d'apartheid en
afrique du sud
ah bon tu t'en non je ne m'en fous pas y
est venu à battre mourir morte servir à
quoi français en russie
je suis passé un deal comme ça avec le
bon dieu tu meurs ya plus l'apartheid tu
veux pas mourir
je demanderai si le pape rende ma copine
quand même été comme ça par thème était
quand même pas pour être engagés dans
des relations l'action sa fenêtre
alors imagine m'attend qui est plus de
pognon campé dans ce coup tape il tape
une thune tout est ruiné en mettre plus
d'argent de terry qu'est ce que tu fais
brûler de l'argent est ce que je serai
prête à aller taper sur des vieux vers
leur faire le sac à la sortie de l'avant
quand ils viennent de toucher leur
retraite ou alors tout a plaidé devant
nous
je préfère un autre plus tôt car taper
dessus ça bancaire coûte
on peut trouver du bon vin tout c'est ce
qui a je souhaite je choisirai les vieux
bon on continue tu as toujours plus
d'argent
est-ce que tu serais prête à devenir
c'est que la mère denis est morte
malheureuse s'est bien repris c'est bien
triste elle est mort est-ce que tu
serais prête à devenir la nouvelle maire
denis pour un million de dollars 1
million de dollars à réfléchir à ça fait
beaucoup d'argent
non non c'est pas prêt ni la nouvelle ni
la nouvelle maire de nuit ni poser à
poil dans le mammy novas n'y ait
personne je préfères tu préfères être
pauvre très pauvre de ton fils le pauvre
maxime il aura pas de quoi s'acheter des
chaussures non merci un jeu imagine
votre épouse un mec riche donc tu
préfères que ton enfant meurt de faim
plutôt que faire la publicité des
machines à laver la télévision c'est
cela m avoir de l'eau nous donnerait le
st jusqu'à ce qu'ils nous ont dit si par
bonheur la chance
pourquoi le mot d'amour le plus con qu
est-ce que c'est merci encore plus vite
oui oui le mot d'amour le plus con way
où on doit vite plus vite d'un mec et
des buts il n'a aucune chance il ya une
chance non parce que j'aime bien j'aime
bien que les choses se fassent cela dans
votre nom dans un rythme pas forcément
rapide
j'aime bien quelque chose c'est face au
tour des prévenus imagine maintenant
celui que les questions qu'on a c'est un
jeu imagine que tu es le choix tu sois
en dix ans soit privé de bouffe c'est à
dire tu est nourri par des sondes
intraveineuse tu ne manges pas ou privés
de sexe sert que tu as les mains
attachées au lit je ne peux rien te
faire même à toi même qu'est ce que tu
choisis pas bouffer ça me gêne pas j'ai
pas été énorme bien que je bien que
j'aime bien la bouffe la bonne bouffe
je peins très bon appétit et puis chaque
sexe ça ne me dérange pas parce que moi
je je je j'ai d'autres palliatifs donc
tellement attaché au lit on est bien
d'accord
oui oui bon d'accord
j'ai toujours mes yeux pour voir bon
d'accord c'est contemplatrice plus tôt
peut-être pour pas dire voyons alors
imagine un soir tu rentre tard le soir
oui tu te fais agresser
oui ça peut arriver est-ce que tu aurais
plus peur de te faire agresser par david
et john atta
c'est terrible c'est terrible licence iv
où débutent les avertissements licence
permettant d'éluder johnattan ils sont
deux ils sont quatre ils sont combien
sont ils sont deux écoutes par david et
d'une vingtaine d'années mais je préfère
parce que je pense que je pourrais à
user de ruse et de super je choisis les
plus et moi les mots en musique en ré -
russie je pourrais on va les avoir moi
plus facilement qu'en maintenant bon ils
t'ont ils t'ont enfermé dans une cave de
hln c'est un jeu wii ta punition préféré
ça se fait lowrie passé l'âge ou mordu
la fesse piqué le david et johnatan
toujours quelque chose à rennes j'ai
atteint mon fils alors il me passe et de
bosses l'oreille il te mordre l'âge où
ils te pique la paix
les joueurs démonte le portrait ne font
rien à vendre mais déjà ils pourront
jamais faire ça bon alors tu arrive chez
toi bon tu t'en fous tu arrive chez toi
oui c'est une sorte de cauchemar
oui tu arrivais pas qu'est ce que la
chose culturelle eu plus peur ce serait
quand ouvre la porte de chez toi
ce serait qu'il ya un rat un fantôme ou
eric charden richer la grèce avant la
wii u ne prennent plus part séparera pas
mon élimination marie entre eric charden
ne pensez vous pas peur des rares ouais
je trouve ça mignon
les fantômes je crois que ça m'excite
beaucoup d'avoir un fantôme chez moi je
crois que j'aurais plus peur par externe
aime parce que vraiment je me
demanderais ce qu'il faut si on arrive
alors maintenant tu vois et richard d'un
an rentrant chez toi tu morte de peur ça
te tue mon blog
imagine tu es morte de peur je vous de
rires oui tu te réincarne tu crois la
réincarnation geste est bon quand tu te
réincarné dans un objet absolument
ridicule un outil train car dans ce lit
tu préfères être incarnée dans le slip
de bar de chirac ou de giscard toute
façon
ils doivent pas près de prendre beaucoup
de place que le slip soirée tranquille
s'arrête peinard tout serait parti
par le dîner qu'il ferait le plus chier
imagine que je viens dîner comme ça un
soir mon privilège
est-ce que tu préférais dîner avec un
sourd muet ou un aveugle bug un son mais
pourquoi je connais pas la langage pour
les aveugles tu pourras te casser
pendant qui pendant qu'ils pouvaient pas
exactement son salut qu'aux chinois et
nord ont remplacé par quelqu'un et puis
on reconnaîtrait pas la différence
alors le mot français je veux tu parle
très bien le français le gros mot
français que tu préfères tu es
est-ce que c'est con merde ou en cuve et
merde avant d'être nommé merde parce que
merde quand je vais arriver en france je
comprenais pas pourquoi tout genre tout
le monde veut remettre dans les bons
délais les chercher on ne peut pas dire
ça c'est interdit
sortez pas la télévision publique à
celui que doit adopter coptes en france
a baissé les prix alors imagine
maintenant que tu rentres chez toi un
soir tu vois ton jules au lit hyde avec
vanessa paradis
on va c'est pas possible pas si c'est
tout à fait ce soir-là recentrer les mii
à la clientèle grandissante
qu'est ce que tu fais mais il faut se
méfier il faut commencer et qu'est ce
que tu fais tous les rejoint dans le lit
tu l'as tu tues de 84 avant l'aspect
encore histoire là après cette nuit que
je tue mail
elle touche par les mondiaux c'est pas
ça prouve qu'elle est mignonne imagine
soit obligé de faire l'amour
sorry j'étais un fusil sur la tempe tu
préfères faire l'amour avec un mec les
ou une fille très jolie jamais été
l'amour avec une fille spycher effet la
moitié sinon c'est en californie quand
même c'est pas quelque chose à ces pays
où les gens on l'espère oui laquelle
fournit oui l'amérique patron non mais
ça me suis jamais je mets le doigt pour
moi c'est qu'on héroïne g dames il est
question oui je souhaite pas de suite
nazi mais des filles je sais pas alors
il est jeune et jolie ou avec très laid
mais je dois dire un mec très déco même
parce que c'est ce que je connais
continuer
avant ça me dégoûte à ce point là
alors je sais pas mais si je suis obligé
je vais faire avec ce que je connais si
j'aime pas l'autre mois avec un mec les
jeux peut fermer les yeux
tu connais bono et goldman oui tu les
connais tout va qui s'était jusque là et
on imagine que tu dois partir dans un
vaisseau spatial pendant quatre ans en
apesanteur à présent terre tu flottes
avec sa femme en quatre ans lequel tu
choisis en fin de match quand même
goldman oui pourquoi l'amour non je ne
supporte pas ça toi dernière question
d'allumer la radio on te dit que la
bombe atomique va tomber dans cinq
minutes
qu'est ce que tu fais c'est des choix
les cinq dernières minutes qui précèdent
c'est à dire toutes les autres mamans et
avant tout que tout le monde va mourir
tard anthony dans 5 minutes à la bombe
alors oui c'est fini pour finir on
demande toujours à quoi ça lui a regardé
je pense que je prendrai mon maigre mais
très bon livre que je m'éclate réponse
la minute au moins bon c'est pas une
preuve que l'amour c'est la plus grande
priorité
on a commencé seul comme ça pour se
mettre en rang se mettre en train qu'est
ce que tu préfères dostoïevski zulawski
où l'on risque explique ben alors
imagine mal an que tu sois comme ce
pauvre je dis là le type qui a écrit les
des versets sataniques été condamné à
mort par l'imam khomeiny
il a dit que tu es buzy tous les
musulmans du monde tu cherches tu
imagines tu vois le tableau et tu
décides de te faire refaire le visage ce
qui serait dommage quand on doit les uns
je te le dire est ce que tu te refaire
le visage comme denise fabre comme
evelyne leclerc ou comme marie-france
cuba là je suis ta personne 15h30 pour
marc daunis fans voudraient ressembler
le sourire alors les nouvelles qui
ferait plus plaisir à la radio est
maintenant entré l'ayant la fin de
l'apartheid la mort de pinochet
j'ai tf1 a supprimé le juste prix mais
résiste assez bien que tout ça je te
comprends maintenant tu es dans un
ascenseur s'est coincé avec qui tu
préférais être coincé dans l'ascenseur
avec juin dernier bernard henri lévy ou
philippe sollers
[Musique]
tu vas être coincé quand il lit à cause
des cheveux du tort ça va lui faire
plaisir
alors ce que tu reproches le plus à dieu
d'avoir mis sur terre les impuissants
les homosexuels les choses on y va
doucement les impuissants
t'as rien contre les shows d'accord
alors maintenant je sors un soir dans
une boîte même c'est pas très mondaine
et pitcho rencontre un mec génial
vraiment s'étudie saliès je craque c'est
le coup de foudre
tu rentres avec lui et tarifs chez toi
et tu as oublié un truc sur la table de
nuit
qu'est ce que c'est qui tombèrent doigt
une puce vis-à-vis de ce mec que tu veux
absolument séduire bien entendu ce
serait d'avoir oublié un godemichet ou
mind gamme
[Rires]
je te comprends alors maintenant tu es
obligé c'est un jeu un peu obligé de
faire l'amour oblige on a été obligé à
un flingue sur la tempe droite et oblige
étaient prisonnières tu es obligé de
faire l'amour qu'est-ce que tu préférais
faire l'amour avec carlos jeter gâtés
car le patient
les proportions catherine lara ou zaza
le chien de michel drucker te fâche bike
drucker je tentais tu as raison disent
que te pardonnera jamais de refuser une
chien de drucker
alors ça ça tu verra demain si bien ça
va faire plaisir à michel brettés
il va être très contente encore
maintenant ton petit ami est un petit
ami il a imaginé
ainsi là il ya des problèmes dont il
n'arrive pas trop à ça peut arriver sur
ça arrive à tout le monde
alors qu'est ce que tu fais tu discutes
en lui disant comment elle s'appelle tu
te trompes
je suis sûr qu'elle a eu notre première
solution deuxième solution tu le fais un
truc spécial troisième solution tu te
casses classe tu te casses attendu le
mec c'était espérons que ce soit face à
hazard est très très mal
bon alors tu rencontres un mec le mec
génial de tout à l'heure l'acteur et
oublier la nasa non tu avais oublié le
godemiché sur la table de nuit alors le
mec bon il est super mais il a un
problème il a le hoquet
il parle sans arrêt ou les très cochon
qu'est ce que ces kits emmerde le moi le
hockey
il n'arrête pas de parler aux lys
insupportable qu'il part le lit du ces
mais qui dit tu me plais toi bon alors
il a le hoquet il parle sans arrêt ou
alors il est très très cochon
qu'est ce que tu préfères moi c'est
drôle c'est drôle alors maintenant
imagine que tu achètes un perroquet
c'est cet apéro tapas de perroquets pour
tâche est un perroquet un jour avec tout
est dit
tout à plat c'est un sublime perroquet
qui apprend tout ce qu'on lui dit une
phrase il arpente est ce que tu préfères
l'ua pour quelle phrase tu lui
apprendrait est ce que tu vas prendre
est visitée oublié de fermer le gaz ce
qui est important est ce que tu lui
apprendrait est ce que le mec a mis sa
capote ou est ce que tu veux prendre
ekoko arrête à coco cocoon
tu rentres chez toi sois qu'est ce qui
te ferait le plus beau de voir mc enroe
leconte ou lendl
c'est monstrueux celui qui te rien plus
peur mcenroe le panther est ce que tu
serais prête à mourir là comme ça
maintenant comme ça sur le champ je vais
te dire pourquoi pour qu'il ait plus
jamais de famine en afrique que tous les
africains puissent manger à leur faim
pendant des siècles et des siècles parce
que tu serais prête à donner ta vie
c'est une question injuste pourquoi pas
ce que j'ai dit on essaie tous de donner
la vie aux scooters aux autres on est
tous nés un peu égoïste quand même donné
d'avis pour quelqu'un d'autre à dire tu
le ferais toi ah non moi je pose la
question alors tu serais pas prêt à
mourir pour que plus jamais de famine en
afrique
non tu serais vraiment site était ruinée
magie d'un jour pas plus d'argent plus
du tout un souffle question qu'est ce tu
préfères réfère pour surveiller pour
élever thézan tu préfèrerais je sais pas
moi taper sur des vieilles dames oui
pour leur piquer leur argent dans leur
sac
quand elles sortent de là de la poste
qu'elles ont touché leur retraite
première solution j'ai pris dans leur
sac puisant leurs sacs tulle et
bastonnent et tu prends le pognon dans
leur sac
ou alors tu te tapes raid et vieux à
monte carlo à marbella pas fait l'amour
avec way au des cochons en plus à ce que
tu préférais mais je crois que j'ai pu
créer dans les sacs les jeux furent
épiques et dans le sens des aiguilles
s'il avait écouté certaines choses
sacrées comme un bon on va dire a obligé
je n'aime pas les deux enfin je
préférais quand même faire le sac des
vieilles que des academy awards est rude
allez y rencontrons turiaf à ces
questions c'est moi qui les fais rien
mais que tu adores c'est absolument
envie de faire l'amour avec lui et toi
tu adores fait craquer folle amoureuse
de lui il a un problème il ya trois
solutions
la première solution il a le hoquet
qu'est ce que c'est bloqué le chat sans
arrêt là le clip la deuxième solution il
parle en faisant l'amour c'est
insupportable de parler en allemand 10
ans arrive à il peut dire des choses je
ne me dis pas les choses je lui dis des
trucs vraiment bon c'est la deuxième
solution est la troisième solution il
est très pervers il très cochon
qu'est ce que tu préfères qu'est ce que
c'est qu'il deviendrait le mois
c'est dans toi
alors je t'écoute
je t'attends tu es un mec qui le hockey
mais notre marque sans arrêt où il est
très cochon un peu de cochonneries ça la
cochonnerie quand même et dit des choses
qui parle bien mais qui n'ont sans doute
tué au pôle nord perdu dans la glace
avec ton jules tu n'as rien à manger
lui il est mort pour survivre tu ne peux
que le manger lui parfois des ti
parfois tu commences par quelle partie
du corps tu commences m
l'âge ou la cuisse le bras levante
tu vas manger quelqu'un que j'aime un
peu d'âme il est mort c'est le chantage
émotionnel mangera toi tu as faim
mathieu est morte oui qu'est ce que tu
veux si c'est la seule façon pour je
survive tellement je rappe qu'est ce que
tu fais d'autres s'arrêtent il mangera
cette paix mustapha ben oui elle est
morte a tellement chouette
oui oui oui pourquoi tu commences
tu sais pas
le doigt la joue
tout ce qui est son cas dernière
question tu pars quatre ans dans un
vaisseau spatial quatre ans tu préfère
partir avec catherine lara bernard tapie
ou yannick noah
diop a répondu non tout ça sinon tu peux
tu réponds que je parte spatiale petit
bassin je parle pour toi lui répondit tu
n'auras sur les échantillons produits
non en fait t'as raison
qu'est ce que tu reproches le plus au
bon dieu vous dire oui au bon dieu les
chauves les impuissants les homosexuels
les homosexuels quand même si tu très
incarnée tu préfères être réincarné en
marguerite duras ou marilyn monroe
alors imagine maintenant quant au greffe
un cerveau il ya trois solutions il ya
trois cerveaux comme ça qui sont vraies
petites boîtes tel choix et dick rivers
eddy mitchell ou johnny hallyday qui
m'apprennent pourtant eux qui vont pas
l'entier du cas pour johnny hallyday et
des mutuelles je dirais pas fort c'est
donc forcément pas d'écrit verte ouais
je prendrai le cargo d'aidé mitchell
avec 26,6 avec géniale idée du projet
d'accord non mais non non non non je le
peux c'est j'ai partagé en deux bon oui
c'est jamais y avoir une suite
david lansky à la caisse que c'est qu'il
ferait le plus content dont jules
rentrer un jour il trouve lit avec
quelqu'un
ah bah maintenant est-ce que ce qui fait
le plus sont ceux qui trouvent au lit
avec une fille avec deux mecs avec qui
mme simon avant tu aurais honte qu'ils
trouvent au lit avec une fille c'est une
copine elle mis d'accord de mec tu t'en
fous ou quoi
domec où elle n'en a sérié un domaine
non mais d'une fine c'est wayne
fitzgerald
je voyais je rappelle purcell taxi be
puis j'aurais peur surtout qu'ils
essaient de venir avec nous deux
c'était devenu une question des ventes
alors le mot d'amour que tu trouves le
plus prompt et là beaucoup hein c'est
merci un mec qui dit merci après l'amour
quand un mec il dit encore ou là mais
qui dit toujours oui oui d'accord on
finit par y arriver alors tu l'a trompée
et tu te dis qu'il n'est pas de punir
est-ce que tu préférais qu'il te pince
qui te mordre pour qui te pique mort en
train de quitter mort de quoi tu qu'il
se rapprocherait fortement tu as entendu
parler du vaisseau spatial c'est un
classique dans cette émission tu pars
quatre ans dans un vaisseau spatial 4 en
apesanteur c'est infernal
alors tu peux partir et jean edern
hallier au nom à henry chapier pourquoi
pas abo quatre ans jeudi
ineo ou catherine lara et dans tous les
voyages à la maison
et puis ce genre d chapier
c'est la question qu'on sait très
l'avait d'adapter un regard par exemple
jusqu'à obliger de faire l'amour
est-ce que tu prête maintenant la well
as là tout de suite devant les caméras
est ce que tu fais il en faudrait peu
parce que pour et comme je suis et que
j'ai pu faire l'amour avec une jolie
fille avec un mec très laid avec un mec
très laid quand même ah bon jamais si
mais je préfère la maintenant tu me
demandes ouais t'es qu'un mec très laid
peut-être parce que tu as essayé et que
c'est à peu près tous mes beaux parents
regardent ils vont retirer la garde de
l'enfant
oui mais justement alors faire une
question qui va faire plaisir à tes
beaux parents ouais ton mec donc ça peut
arriver leur fils à un soir que s'il
arrive pas à m'enlever ça arrivait
toujours la science-fiction toujours oui
j'espère pour toi en tous les cas
alors qu'est-ce que tu choisis tu
discutes avec lui tu lui dis c'est cette
fille ou tu la connais tu m'aimes plus
qu'est ce que je t'ai fait ma première
solution
qu'est ce qu'une solution tu fais un
truc très spécial tu connais tu sais que
ça lui plaît les troisièmement tu te
casses en claquant la porte en disant
connard je préfère la toute première
solution parce que c'est alexis très
complètement que tu lui parles de la
fille même si c'est pas vrai avant tu
discutes un jeu alors maintenant on va
faire les moeurs oui comment tu
préférerais mourir mais en fait il que
tu vas en angleterre un stade tu
préfèrerais mourir tué par un skinhead
tué dans un accident d'avion ou tués
dans un stade tout ça est typiquement
anglais bien
l'accident d'avion parce que du coup je
rentrerai dans la légende du rock genre
comme de diorite où ça allait me
reviennent en avait jusque là on les
critique rome du coup dans rain man
justement si tu devais mourir comme une
star du rock tu préférais mourir comme
otis redding ou buddy holly
oui en avion comme john lennon avec un
coup de revolver dans le ventre comme ça
à bout portant
rp chine à ces jeunes tout peut arriver
comme janis joplin d'une overdose
non non ça craint et comme le mec da si
d'ici là bonne scott tu sais qui est
mort dans son vomi
alors comme otis redding comme otis
redding toujours l'avion j'ai tellement
peur en avion qui me dit un jour ça que
tu les prends pas si je le prends les
devants chaque fois c'est genre ah bon
testament avant et que tu fais tu bois
n'ont rien je suffit pas mais alors
imagine que le petit adrien coutume
heures dont tu es morte
ouais d'accord maintenant laisser le jeu
tu es morte le petit adrien il est
confiée à la mère n'ont pas la taille
justement est-ce que tu préférais qu'il
soit confié à france gall team gym à
dakar ça sera un tube abaca oui bon il
soit confiée à françoise hardy non
atteints vas-y un front sylvie vartan ou
shellac sujet fait des classiques
sheila sylvie vartan secours parce que
vraiment on secoure qu'elle fait
on se servait j'aime bien ouais c'est
entre sheila et françoise hardy away
celle un côté comme ça rassurant et tous
vents et en ce moment là pas trop de
boulot elle pourrait sans doute
bon allez on planche et la question
traditionnelle sont pas si cons csel
risques ne sont pas conduites ou des
questions le vaisseau spatial fans sont
moins cons que hier le vaisseau spatial
ouais tu es prête ouais bon avec qui tu
préférais partir fais gaffe parce que là
tout vers jean te regarde réfléchit bien
tu pars avec mon max guazini de nrj a dû
être fâché avec un fc sion avec patrice
blanc francard d'europe numéro un
oui avec monique le mars id rtl ou et
catherine lara parce qu'elle est là
toutes les semaines il y avait elle
aurait tu t'en fais gaffe parce qu'à la
fin je tirais max parce qu'il est beau
garçon
ouais c'est bien c'est dire ils vont
faire ça il est formidable bond il
ferait pas de rendre unique et beau
garçon
oui et après en me faisant peur quand
même a répliqué quatre ans avec max
guazini maxi qui est vraiment il est
surprenant comme garçons j'apprendrai
choix des duos avec les gens d'un lidl a
annoncé jeudi max parce que monique les
marci
parce que oui mboulou première radio de
france
bah oui mais quand j'ai vu des garçons
bon alors entravé la main et de leurs
frontières contre et non pas comme un
email
pour réussir dans le showbiz oui tu veux
réussir dans le showbiz bah vous devons
aller au cameroun par exemple dans un
château en château bon est-ce qu'il faut
être super vicieuse super tueuse ou
super magouilleuse super maquilleuse
super magouilleuse tu rentres chez toi
un soir qu'est ce qui te ferait le plus
peur de voir fabius giscard sous la
porte
fabius jusqu'à simone veil ou david et
john atta
[Musique]
jusqu'à pourquoi parce que vraiment lui
dangereux
il est trop vicieux est pour moi un
texte dessus alors j'aurais surtout
faire qu'une boîte ou médias mondiaux a
envie d'avoir un perroquet pas
spécialement parce que comme je fais
beaucoup de cachotteries répèterai tout
ce que je dis moi imagine que tu as un
perroquet quelle phrase tu apprendras en
première ta ferme et dégage tu as pensé
à la capote ou coco arrête là coco
pas fermer le gaz parce que j'ai une
cuisinière qui fuit en ce moment ça
serait très bien dit il va comment le
petit julien trêve iñaki fabien quel âge
il a 5 ans et demi cinq ans et demi ça
pousse
il commence à jouer de la gratte un peu
moins nombreuse romande ou pas
d'agrément il joue du synthé là alors
ils s'enregistrent et un truc super
imagine que tu meurs tu un jeu wii et
l'orphelin bah oui tu préfèrerais qu'ils
soient confiées à qui la jeanne mas à
france gall ou à vanessa paradis
ben ali ça à bon voilà ta copine ouais
bon pourquoi pas jeanne mas parce
qu'au-delà des fixes pourquoi tu l'as
laiteuse
ce que je trouve qu'elle est là quelque
chose aux phalanges la déteste pas non
non ça c'est méchant je trouve qu'elle
est antipathique abord à cause de la
peine de mort à cause de tout quoi
j'aime pas j'aime pas les gens qui s'est
pas qu'ils prennent les photos visage
qui trouvent qu'elle veut avoir l'air
poste et qu'elle est pas par exemple que
c'est ça et cette petite année paraît si
tu pars sur une île déserte
oui paris qu'un mec ouais
tu partiras avec un blanc un noir un jeu
ou un rouget
emma avec un blanc parce que les noirs
ils sont trop matches ont pu voir avant
que ça continue cette histoire ils
sautaient d'une militante
oui complètement les geôles alors qu'ils
sont trop business tu vois c'est la
singapore ils m'ont pris la tête et les
blancs vraiment c'est qu'ils sont sympas
à situer avec les femmes femmes noires
les récents vachement attentionné moi
j'adore ça j'attends qu'on soit assez
grand kiss par les blocs ou le plan
j'espère un jour tu vas au cameroun
comment tu vas faire alors battre angers
angers dans le mot d'amour le plus nul
maintenant là qu'il ya un truc au lit
qui dit l'un des mots que je vais te
citer il ya aucune chance avec toi juin
salle tout de suite tu te dire c'est
merci merci
encore encore
[Musique]
plus vite plus vite oui oui c'est ça
qu'est ce qui te plaît le moins acheté
une chance avec toi et marche est un mec
qui dit merci merci ca et celui que tu
préfères vais encore courir ou encore
ses besoins en hausse et c'est bien
normal on est obligé de faire l'amour
revolver couteau grenade t'obliger il
préfère faire l'amour avec une très
jolie fille avec un mec très laid
[Musique]
avec un mec très long ballon pascal fils
et tu vois c'est ce que pense et là les
fidjiens cdh a essayé ça te plaît pas du
tout à ça tu préfères un mec trail et
oui ça c'est sûr et solide quand je vous
disais les villages way to imagine que
tout soit violée c'est terrible ce jeu
oui c'est les pires question qu'on va te
poser pendant toute la campagne de
promotion qui permet de suivre il tombe
voisine papa de cl tu verras alors est
ce que tu préfères être violée par
yannick noah harlem désir ou isaac de
bankolé je dirais les trois à bon il est
toujours là puisque vous voulez un choix
je dirais quand même
yannick parce que c'est un compatriote
depuis à bon je n'ai pas de complexe
quoi tu vois où la peur qu'il ait mal au
genou
waouh ça fera pas plaisir harlem et à
isaac baron mais tant pis tant pis pour
empoisonnement
mais bon le vaisseau spatial à 4 ans
dans le vaisseau spatial a transmis
beaucoup joué beaucoup en apesanteur
la liste est longue ppda a priori
prairies non pourquoi
c'est que cette merde même oublié tes
nerfs parce qu'on ne sait pas s'il est
stoïque ce parisien historique qui se
passait là il réagit pas à quoi tu
penses à bord ont changé je n'apprécie
pas spécialement par ppda bruno masure
avis par honte à le dire avant lui il a
une chance la chance
sabatier sa bâtisse historique robot
mois d'août
c'est ça le problème est encore drucker
halloween c'est d'abord j'adore donc
bien sûr tu sens que ça va être du caire
je sens que si la balle de celui-ci à
foucault tricare drucker toujours bien
sûr collaro au caire l'objet de la
vitesse pas noir blanc est de rigueur
ouais donc qu'ils trouvent sexy le cd
intelligent alors vous me ferez la
conversation ou catherine lara donc je
vais te poser des questions qu'on t'a
rien qu'on a parce qu'avant si on
continue tu préfères hitler ou staline
même combat alors tu dois partir trois
ans dans un vaisseau spatial ya kim
bassinger juin robert non c'est pire que
jamais entre dans la tuerait va pas non
plus il ya dave à sainte foy les charges
on sait pas combien hervé vilard
et la tactique j'y vais on voit mieux
prendre les trois parce que trois elles
s'arrangeront alors
tu as vraiment pas le choix est ce que
tu préfères faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide ou un mec très beau à la
bosch ah bon oui c'est ça tapait
beaucoup des matches oui toute manière
comme ça on est sûr d'en avoir une belle
un jour un accord oui c'était ce qui
peut t'arriver oui tu préférais te
réincarné en patrick sabatier jean
pierre foucault michel drucker faut le
faire face et dit qu'il avait des
questions très con s'il s'agit de
revenir sur terre au nom vaut mieux
rester au chul pour toi à qui tu trouve
le plus de circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles et
bien sûr le staff n'était pas bon bien
sûr comment à ton avis comment
reconnaît-on les filles des garçons
alors les petites filles ont des fentes
et les garçons des rugbymen nancy et wc
bien sûr alors dis-moi rend pas sortir
du géant allemand est ce que tu préfères
draguer ou de faire draguer je prends le
salut les copains se rappelle de ses
niveaux sur braga qui préfèrent la rime
verlinghem et leurs yeux la dernière
fois que tu as pleuré pour une femme
c'était quand mon grand
quand mon tout petit mais pas compte ni
le montant
y'avait longtemps fini tout ça ouais
elle peur pour toi notons cependant plus
loin tu dors nu ou habillé je dors
mulhouse haut rhin
tu pour faire la chose tu éteins la
lumière où tu laisses la lumière allumée
manière je suis myope des filiales à
muriel sur ta tirer des expériences
homosexuelles n'en verse une septième
recours à l'amour tarifé ta main l'amour
tarifé sur ta bulle un ballet put quoi
on appelle ça comme ça à la télé parce
que sinon ce point là nous c'est une
émission sur le service public à des
mots qu'on peut prendre bien sûr
pourquoi n'y la dernière fois c'était
quand je pense au jeu au risque pas de
le dire
indiquons à la télé je vais te poser
quelques questions qu'ont ces prêts asie
est ce que tu préfères tu en perds ta
mère profite tant ils sont mortes il
savait pas non
c'est un peu gênant je destine erreur et
c'est la première
j côté dit tu dois partir trois ans dans
un vaisseau spatial
tu as le choix est ce que tu partirais
avec des patrick juvet pour hervé vilard
en orbite avec 30 à pet est propre et
dénis
c'est un peu peiné
favalli s'il y arrive je te connais
pouilly et la vie continue
si tu avais vraiment pas le choix est ce
que tu préfères et faire l'amour avec
une fille très très laide ou un mec très
très beau entendu parler de ça c'est
nouveau ça vient de sortir
tu préfères être incarnée en patrick
sabatier jambières pourquoi ou michel
drucker s'échappe trafiquants
à qui devrait tuer le plus de
circonstances atténuantes à un jeune qui
tapent sur des vieilles ou un vieux qui
se tape des jeunes ça se discute ce pays
avant des bas disons plutôt et donne
quoi
ouais et s'entraider entre collègues tu
rentres chez toi le soir très tard
qu'est ce qui te ferait le plus peur
dans le noir le pen tapis le pen tapis
noir
[Applaudissements]
y at il une vie avant la mort continue à
me faire chier tu attendais le savent
rien
des punitions préféré c'est d'être mort
du passé ou battu essayé et ça y est le
mot le plus con en amour c'est merci oui
ou encore le temps de la bouche elle
naquit pendant dix ans pas de bouffe ou
peut être q qu'est-ce que tu prends ta
peau vécu
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était pile aller pointer au
chômage et vittel c'est fait pour les
chiens c'est les fameuses questions cons
à lola ohlala alors ça commence
simplement tu es jarretelles ou collante
ses collants bande à corte soutien gorge
ou seins nus
bon ok j'ai pas vraiment toujours trouvé
amataï c'était à dire que la tessin et
tu veux dire
torse nu est ce que tu es slip ou
caleçon quel chouette
ah ouais j'avoue ça décale fouet et oui
pas mal oui y'a des 400 sous cette robe
là pas question d'aider des grands h un
des grands machins eux est-ce que tu
préfèrerais mourir les dentelles soit
machin non non tu comprends tu sois tu
dis que tu arrives pas tu marier mais tu
comprends si tu si tu dis je me dis
jamais tu préfèrerais mourir rayon laser
bombe à neutrons ou gaz inodore au laser
ça fait plus spectacle aux us et d'un
malgache gaz inodore tu avais pas je
transpirais
[Applaudissements]
si tu pouvais continuer à tendre les
invités de ce nom c'est bien changer
tout ça c'est bien continuez monsieur
baffe
alors imagine imagine que tu sois
coincés dans un ascenseur veut déjà
imagine que tu sois coincés dans un
ascenseur
tu préfères être coincé avec qui
catherine lara on se marre pas muriel
robin ou marie paule belle
non non je ne sais pas choisissant une
un ascenseur c'est pour une navette
spatiale qui par leur audace et raconte
des histoires ah ouais muriel robin avec
toi dans un ascenseur pendant qu'en même
temps du tiendrait des bois c'est
l'ascenseur qui risquent pas tout alors
ton julie arrive par imagine c'est une
supposition tout ça c'est des questions
suppositions suppositions ton julien
riffard tu lui demande comment elle
s'appelle premières suppositions
deuxième suppositions tu lui fais un
truc spécial pour qu'ils y arrivent
troisièmes suppositions tu te casses en
claquant la porte
[Rires]
à demain tu te casses en claquant la
porte à la porte des buts on va bien on
verra demain la question suivante
j'aimerais mettre la pesée pas ici quoi
pas de vent pas devant tout le monde au
fonds ou alors nous voilà à pas loin
d'accord tu viens ok
oui demande aurait été si tu devais
partir sur une sur une île déserte
tu choisirais qui entre de chavannes de
caunes frédéric mitterrand au moins dû
provoquer mais je suis obligé dire toi
non franchement j'ai franchement toi ça
va pas être triste mais vrai tu prends
ma mois que s'il va tirer une semaine
sur l'île déserte avec moi une semaine
ça va c'est pas le fait de miser sur les
joueurs
produits oui quand même
on y retourne pas laisser tout seul non
on va quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
je te dirais pas ça je crois que c'est
bon bon moi je crois que c'est bon pour
moi j'essaie opel n'a pas marché mais
j'ai une ouverture c'est vous alors tu
es prêt on va passer aux questions qu'on
est d'accord est pas on essaie aussi ok
d'accord
tpr est là pour répéter la question est
ce que fut tu préfères staline ou hitler
j'avais android clair que je me sens
puisqu'on sait tu dois partir de 3 ans
dans un vaisseau spatial
tpr est là tu préfères des hervé vilard
ou patrick juvet comprendre d'eux comme
ça il s'occupe
il préférait faire l'amour avec une
fille très très très laide ou un mec
très très très beau oui je suis très
très très laide
ah ben quand même à lui les mecs s'était
jamais arrivé tôt en plus acquis
trouves-tu le plus de circonstances
atténuantes jacques pradel un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui
tapent sur des vieilles des petites de
quel âge à peu près 12 13 ans quoi 10 13
ans mais biche d'or doubs
voilà [ __ ] 20 jeunes qui tapent sur
une vieille dans la vie de la vieille a
déjà été fait
elle a eu déjà des joueurs tandis que la
jeune tu l'unique tout de suite à 12 en
série ces questions pour moi mais c'est
un surnom mais c'est bien c'est bien
donc disons ça disons la vie le mot le
plus con en amour
merci encore oui oui merci merci merci
comme si tu penses pas de le dire
pendant dix ans qu'est ce tu choisis pas
de bouffe ou pas de cul ben je n'utilise
pas de pad brapad bouffe est un droit du
goût fait le culte
c'est pour ça que résister
mais j'ai confié tu bouffes pas beaucoup
alors qu'est ce tu prends pas de bouffer
fait pas de but ouais ouais bah qu'est
ce qu'une question
ouais d'accord mais là tu préfères être
réincarné en bergers allemands setter
irlandais ou épagneul breton web berger
allemand jour un boulot en plus un
berger allemand joue peut-être je suis
gay demandes nazies je lui mort des
couilles la bombe arides en cinq minutes
tu fais quoi
je continue interview je suis un
professionnel
est-ce que tu accepterais d'échangés toi
d'échanger une paralysie générale contre
la faim de la faim en somalie et au
soudan et au souhait au soudan elle et
le mali le mali à les tuer paralysé
jusqu'à la fin de tes jours allongée sur
un lit de légumes dégâts si ces gens-là
mangent à leur faim
d'accord pas encore pendant tout le
temps tout le temps hayat urbain des
impôts en france que la fin la somalie
le soudan et le mali non ce jeu tu veux
pas non je continue à courir et je sais
qu'il est honnête il fera jamais de
politique
renard pas un fauteuil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
préfèrerais mourir comme en rayon laser
bombe à neutrons ou gaz inodore
c'est bien c'est tout bien la marque
ouais donc norway n'importe quoi je m'en
fous rayon laser ça fait impossible et
en laser sait comment il meurt lahdjar
au nom du perroquet chez toi tu lui
apprendrait d'affaires mais le gaz tu as
pensé à la capote ou coco arrête là coco
tu as pensé à la cathode à penser à la
capote fera un perroquet qui dirait ça
voilà est-ce que tu préfèrerais que tu
avais le choix est reclus jah tous
impuissants ou alors tu dois être comme
ça j'ai des collègues qui serait nulle
part
très bien donc tu préférais que j'ai un
puissant non si c'est possible je
préférais par les pointures de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu